Facebook of course is increasingly a bad
actor in the world of disseminating
truth of prioritising fact over
propaganda in the world of limiting the
destructive effect of actual fake news
and lies on the Internet I don't mean
fake news
the way Trump uses it which is any news
he doesn't like I mean actual
disinformation propaganda Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg imploded
recently when he was questioned by
congresswoman Alexandria Casio courts
has a few weeks ago we covered it for
you and it's getting worse because we
learned not long ago that Donald Trump
and Mark Zuckerberg had a meeting now it
was initially a secret meeting in the
sense that it didn't appear on Donald
Trump's schedule anywhere Facebook
didn't report that this meeting between
Trump and Zuckerberg had taken place
eventually the news of the meeting did
surface thanks to an NBC news report and
of course only then did Facebook say
well yeah we did actually have that
meeting and it was actually back in
October when Zuckerberg had that
terrible appearance before Congress so
Mark Zuckerberg appears on CBS this
morning yesterday and is interviewed by
Gayle King Gayle King asks him about the
meeting and Zuckerberg devolves into
just meaningless stuttering visibly
uncomfortable it is not good it is not
good take a look we were in DC recently
there it was reported later that you had
dinner with the president of the White
House what was the nature of the meeting
can you say sure I mean we talked about
a number of things that were they were
on his mind and I mean some of the
topics that you've read about in the
news around around our work we talked
about a number of things and topics in
the news super clear mark crystal-clear
I totally understand it and she tried to
follow up on the question and it
actually gets even worse people would
say the optics weren't good did he try
to lobby you in any way no I mean I
don't think that that's that I think
some of the stuff that people talk about
or think gets discussed and these
discussions are not really how okay how
that works I also want to respect that
it was a private dinner did he Lobby you
know some stuff people talk about things
that you know it's
not always as discussed so I get it it
was a private meeting that's not a
defense though that's actually part of
the problem as I see it
Donald Trump is publicly talking about
Facebook should do this Facebook should
do that Facebook should not do this
other thing
Zuckerberg testifies before Congress on
exactly the same issues it's a train
wreck that gives off vibes that this is
truly a terribly bad faith actor they
keep the meeting not just private but
secret they're outed and then he says a
meaningless word salad and says you know
it was a private meeting anyway so I
have to be careful now I do actually
think that Donald Trump and Zuckerberg
probably did not plan nefarious things
in the meeting I don't think it's that
explicit I mean they may be nefarious in
some ways but if you're imagining this
cartoonish secret meeting where they're
whispering about all of the nefarious
things that are going to do on Facebook
to help Donald Trump I don't think that
anything that cartoonish or dramatic
took place this is just how the hubs of
power continue chugging along Peter
Thiel was also at the meeting which only
raises even more red flags that's a
story for another day if you don't know
who Peter Thiel is I envy you that that
that's great now let me propose one
thing that would be maybe maybe the only
thing that makes Mark Zuckerberg word
salad answer a little bit less
disturbing Trump often doesn't know what
the hell he's talking about and nobody
around him does is it possible that the
reason Mark Zuckerberg struggled to say
what was discussed is because he didn't
understand what on earth Donald Trump
was talking about is that maybe why he
was unable to answer Gale Kings question
I'm kidding sort of mostly but who knows
my guess is that the topics from that
meeting will ultimately play a role in
the 2020 election there's too much at
stake right now the dynamics the power
dynamics of what a platform like
Facebook can do when it comes to
influencing elections by virtue of what
they do and don't allow the stakes are
extremely high and I would be shocked if
whatever was discussed between Trump and
Zuckerberg doesn't ultimately play
role in the 2020 election let me know
what you think was talked about